[Musik]
willkommen beim live an diesem freitag
vormittag es gibt momente und es gibt
menschen die lassen einen nicht mehr los
wie dieser mann seine augen sie haben 37
tage krieg gesehen aus ihnen spricht
traurigkeit tiefe traurigkeit aber auch
absolute entschlossenheit wladimir
klitschko auf blitzbesuch hier in berlin
termin im kanzleramt im
wirtschaftsministerium und auch hierbei
bild ein intensives interview über das
wir jetzt sprechen wollen mit bild
chefredakteur johannes breuer ein
interview in dem klitschko auch das hier
sagt
wenn man ein passiver beobachter ist
hat man auch
das blut auf eigene
passiv zu sein heißt mitzumachen
wegschauen heißt mitzumachen
es darf nicht sein dass diese frei wild
auf die man so sicher rentiert
auch denen die sich dafür entschieden
haben und auch ihre lieben mit ihrem
leben bezahlen nicht mit euro
mit leben
wegschauen heißt mitzumachen bild chef
johannes bei uns im studio das sind
worte die schüttelt man nicht einfach
wieder ab die bleiben in uns nach diesem
besuch von wladimir klitschko bei uns
was kann dieser besuch bei uns allen in
deutschland bei der regierung bewegen
bei uns allen in deutschland bin ich
sicher dass er viel bewegt denn wladimir
klitschko ist ein botschafter aus dem
krieg heraus und er ist ein botschafter
auch wenn er prominent ist und hier
besonders als schwergewichts boxer in
bester erinnerung ist ist ja doch ein
botschafter der eben kein
spitzenpolitiker ist er kein militär ist
es ein ja fast mensch wie du und ich er
hat es erlebt und wenn man ihnen gestern
in die augen geschaut hat wenn man ihn
hier im auftritt gesehen hat hat man
gesehen was der krieg mit den menschen
macht
es ist sehr dunkel geworden um ihnen und
in ihm das wurde mit jedem satz klar das
war bewegend zu sehen und ich glaube ist
es ganz wichtig dass diese stimmung und
diese situation eben auch hier
präsentiert wird und gezeigt wird denn
wir leben ja und so leben doch irgendwie
weiter auch wenn wir sehr große und sehr
schwierige debatten führen dass die
bevölkerung was der besuch in der
regierung zu bewegen vermag bin ich
unsicher bin ich nicht klar darüber denn
wir sehen ja ein ständiges schwanken der
deutschen bundesregierung zwischen
beschwichtigenden hilfreichen worten
aber nicht wirklich liefern dann gibt es
phasen da wird wieder ein bisschen
geliefert da geht dann aber auch wieder
viel schief vielleicht sprechen wir
heute noch darüber und deswegen
bin ich sicher dass es auch für die
politikerinnen und politiker bewegend
war aber ob es was gebracht hat habe ich
sorge nicht wegen ihm wegen der
deutschen bundestag sprechen genau über
diese lieferung und man hatte gestern
johannes in diesem gespräch den eindruck
dass vladimir klitschko sehr sehr
versucht all das mit großer höflichkeit
zu sagen jetzt nicht als fordern das
schwergewicht hier aufzutreten sondern
ganz ganz höflich mit einer wunschliste
das hat wladimir klitschko hat zugesagt
ist marina wir brauchen mehr
wir brauchen mehr und brauchen jetzt wir
haben keine zeit wir haben keine zeit
das war so ein nachdrücklicher satz den
er dann nachschub und das wie gesagt mit
großer höflichkeit er wollte jetzt nicht
vorpreschen nicht zu fordert seit dabei
hätte er allen grund eigentlich auf den
putz zu hauen und sagen mensch ihr
deutschen liefert wenigstens das was wir
uns versprochen hat die ukraine haben
der bandbreite ist ja mal einen sehr
aggressiven botschafter für den ich
alles verständnis dieser welt habe weil
er eben sieht in seiner heimat sterben
die menschen seine freunde und bekannten
sterben jetzt haben wir eine stillere
vielleicht auch ein paar tische stimme
aus der ukraine erlebt auch dafür habe
ich natürlich alle größtes verständnis
die botschaft ist aber die gleiche und
sie ist beides mal mit großer vehemenz
einmal laut und hart und einmal
getrieben von den erinnerungen von dem
unmittelbaren erleben des krieges
vorgetragen nämlich die ukraine brauchen
jetzt hilfe sie brauchen jetzt waffen
und mein eindruck bei meinem gespräch
mit wladimir klitschko nach seinem
auftritt im studio war auch dass es für
ihn sehr schwer begreifbar ist das hier
das normale leben ja ein stück weit
einfach weitergeht er ist hier ein
getaktet in die slots der politiker vor
ihm kommt jemand nach ihm kommt jemand
der da vor keine ahnung redet vielleicht
über die büroeinrichtung der neuen
minister und der danach kommt redet
vielleicht über die nächste
bundestags-abstimmung und zwischendrin
kommt er und er redet über leben und tod
über tod vor allem und dieser normalität
auch dieses
funktionieren eines demokratischen
staates was er gut ist aber erleben zu
müssen die langsamkeit mit der
entscheidung getroffen werden während
minütlich menschen in der ukraine
ermordet werden von russischen truppen
das ist für ihn unerträglich das hat man
gemerkt und ja ich glaube auch er hat
gar nicht er hat gar nicht die kraft im
moment um mit der faust auf den tisch zu
hauen der mann ist möchte ihn nicht zu
nahe treten nicht würde es sehr gut
verstehen wenn das so wäre aber ist
womöglich traumatisiert nach knapp 40
tagen im krieg das ist angesprochen die
ukraine braucht waffen in diesem
zusammenhang müssen wir aber auch über
diese geschichte reden die heute auch
bei uns in der zeitung ist die ukraine
braucht vor allem auch die richtigen
waffen erst verschleppte die
bundesverteidigungsminister christine
lambrecht waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt
durch diesen bericht heraus deutschland
liefert sogar die falschen waffen hier
bei uns johannes beer weiterhin im
studio ist das nicht eine totale blamage
für uns doch vollkommen absolut daran
gibt es nichts schönzureden ich nehme
die bundesregierung
differenziert war es gibt glaube ich
ministerinnen und minister die wollen
schneller ich finde insbesondere die
grüne partei die wir bei bild auch immer
wieder sehr hart kritisiert haben zeigt
aber hier doch ganz klare kante
gegenüber russland habe tut was er kann
annalena baerbock hat sinngemäß gesagt
es sei für sie kaum erträglich
zuzugucken
aber ausgerechnet das
verteidigungsministerium wird von einem
ministerium geleitet die man muss es
leider sagen ihren laden überhaupt nicht
im griff hat auch ein eindruck den ich
selbst bei recherchen zwischenzeitlich
gewonnen habe diese ministerin hat noch
vor ein paar wochen gesagt wir hätten im
grunde gar keine waffen die man schicken
könnte es gebe nur ein paar alte pizzen
zwischenzeitlich hat sich die zeit
vollkommen eine fehleinschätzung einfach
erst sie war nicht aufstand als der
krieg schon begonnen hatte immer und
immer wieder sagt sie dinge die sich im
nachhinein als falsch herausstellen und
hier wäre jetzt eben jemand gefragt ja
das verteidigungsministerium so im griff
hat das zack zack zack geliefert wird
produziert wird ohne bürokratische
hürden und so weiter dort bekommt sie
nicht hin eine katastrophe trägt dazu
bei dass ukrainerinnen und der ukraine
unter druck geraten und möglicherweise
sogar sterben und eben diesen tagen in
diesen zeiten trifft sich vladimir
klitschko auch heute weiter mit
regierungsmitgliedern am vormittag
offenbar mit annalena baerbock der
außenministerin am abend mit dem
kanzleramtsminister zuvor mit dem
wirtschaftsminister all das passiert
heute noch wir haben im studio hier mit
wladimir klitschko auch gesprochen über
all die millionen ukrainer die zu uns
gekommen sind vor allen dingen frauen
und kinder und man merkte er steckt in
einem gewaltigen dilemma natürlich
fordert er von uns und das ist all
unsere große aufgabe diese menschen
diese kinder diese frauen so schnell wie
möglich bestmöglich zu integrieren und
gleichzeitig sind das natürlich all die
menschen die er so schnell wie möglich
wieder zurück haben möchte bei sich in
der ukraine
wissen sie was die kinder wollen ich
weiß es nach hause
so einfach wie es ist die wollen nach
hause weil da sind ihre
lieblingsspielzeuge
das sind ihre freunde die denken so dass
sie zu hause
wo sie ihre erste begeisterung gelebt
haben in den wänden aber die wissen
nicht und die verstehen nicht und das
weiß ich dass das hat zu hause nicht
existiert das leben was sie davor gehabt
haben gibt es nicht mehr
ich weiß was die kinder holen
die wurzeln
in der heimat natürlich bedanken
die familien
dass deutschland so viele flüchtlinge
schon aufgenommen hatte
das kann man aber nicht ersetzen das
zuhause gefühl
die stadt
das dorf
wo man aufgewachsen ist wo man das so
stark lebt die sprache
auch ein thema und viel mehr
und deswegen nicht weiß was sie können
dabei auch die wohnung nach hause
deswegen müssen wir schnellstmöglich
verdienen schaffen
einer dieser momente in diesem interview
der mir zu das sprichwörtlich das herz
bricht johannes mit all diesen kindern
wie können wir vorgehen natürlich ist es
unsere pflicht sie zu integrieren
gleichzeitig wollen sie nach hause ihr
zuhause aber komplett zerstört man muss
diesen kindern in den ländern in denen
sie jetzt sind es so einfach wie möglich
machen es so gut wie möglich machen wir
wissen nicht wann sie zurück können das
hängt von vielen faktoren ab auch
ehrlich gesagt davon ob die
bundesregierung es jetzt endlich schafft
vernünftig regelmäßig waffen zu schicken
deswegen müssen wir uns bei aller
emotionalität auch sachfragen stellen
wir müssen gucken dass die integriert
werden dass der schulunterricht weit
geht alles was kindern stabilität gibt
aber natürlich muss das oberste ziel
bleiben dass die ukraine so befreit wird
so stabilisiert wird dass diese kinder
zurück können
und es sind ja in anführungszeichen
nicht nur die schicksale die klitschko
gestern bei bild live im interview
genannt hat es gibt auch viele kinder
die haben ihre eltern verloren
kinder die schwerstens traumatisiert
sind ich habe die geschichte gelesen von
einer frau die geflohen ist auf dem weg
zum bus sah sie ein kind an der
bushaltestelle sitzen neben seinen
erschossenen eltern
sie packte das kind allen kannte den
namen nicht hat es mitgenommen nach
deutschland auch mit solchen schicksalen
müssen wir umgehen und wir sind als
westen dazu aufgefordert hier wirklich
auch unsere besten psychologinnen und
psychologen ins spiel zu schicken um zu
helfen all diese bilder diese szenen die
du gerade auch geschildert hast den
ausschnitten die erlebt vladimir
klitschko seit mehr als einem monat
jeden tag darauf natürlich angesprochen
wie sehr ihn dieser krieg verändert
es ist das leben vor dem krieg
und ich vor dem krieg und ich während
des kriegs ich kann dir sagen macht und
krieg während des krieges das hat jeden
verendet in ausnahmen in der ukraine
jeden verändert ganz anders
manche weniger die anderen die
diesen horror erlebt haben noch mehr
jan ist wie hast du diesen veränderten
klitschko wahrgenommen und inwiefern der
krieg vermutlich uns alle verändert
es gibt viele bilder von menschen vor
dem krieg und nach dem krieg aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg aus vietnam es sind
bilder die immer wieder beeindruckend
wenn man sie in magazinen oder auch im
internet
18 jähriger mit dem krieg kommt als
21-jähriger zurück sieht aus wie 45 tief
gezeichnet man sieht die man der wird
das vollständige lebensglück nie wieder
erlangen das sind schicksale die kannten
wir in europa bislang nur aus der
geschichte oder von flüchtlingen die es
zu uns geschafft haben jetzt kennen wir
sie aus europa wieder und das eine
tragödie und ich musste an diese bilder
denken die also bekannt sind als ich
gestern wladimir klitschko traf denn man
kennt ihn ja durchaus noch als den
umjubelten champion
als starken und menschen der natürlich
von seiner statur her immer noch ist
aber da ist doch irgendwas zerbrochen
und
ich glaube es war deshalb so wichtig
dass er zu besuch kam
denn es spiegelt und in deutschland doch
sehr genau nicht nur wie gut wir es
haben und wir unser leben eben doch noch
relativ unbeeindruckt weiter geht
sondern auch wie unterschiedlich die
wahrnehmung ist wladimir klitschko sagt
die mir gestern die ukraine werden
kämpfen bis zum schluss und er erzählte
geschichten von 60 65 jährigen männern
die ihre wohnung verloren haben und er
sprach medien und sagte was können wir
tun braucht eine neue wohnung und wie
können wir helfen und der mann sagt ich
brauche keine wohnung ich brauche ein
maschinengewehr der wollte kämpfen ja
obwohl man mit 65 dafür vielleicht nicht
mehr und er hat es diese geschichten
erzählt und er hat diese geschichten
übrigens auch auf meine frage erzählt
was eigentlich die strategischen
möglichkeiten für die ukraine sind und
vor ort wenn dir deine heimat zerbombt
wird stellt sich womöglich gar nicht so
sehr die frage wie können wir verhandeln
was machen wir die ukraine wollen 1 die
wollen waffen und die wollen dass die
russen verschwinden und die werden
kämpfen bis zur letzten minute und diese
unterschiedliche wahrnehmung wo wir in
deutschland ja auch viel darüber reden
wie muss man zu handeln was kann die
diplomatie leisten alles ja schon
irgendwie wichtige fragen aber diese
unterschiedliche wahrnehmung worüber wir
hier reden und was er erlebt war für
mich das beeindruckendste an dem besuch
und ich wünsche ihm deshalb
dass es ein großer erfolg für ihn ist
und dass seine worte hier verfangen es
ist zumindest kaum vorstellbar johannes
dass man ihm etwas abschlagen kann
werden dass hier auch im studio erlebt
die aura dieses mannes die wirklich viel
auch diesen raum erfüllt und ich stelle
es mir sehr schwierig vor wenn er so
eindringlich dass schildert was passiert
was er erlebt wie es den menschen in der
ukraine geht dann in ein entgegen zu
sagen das ist mit sicherheit nicht ganz
so einfach danke bild chef johannes
bolena es im studio und gleichzeitig
merkte man bei diesem besuch hier